have either of you been stung by a
scorpion no
no but i think kirsten said she did she
did i hear it's very painful yeah
you could just step on them accidentally
my mother-in-law did because she thought
that actually it was a leaf that's how
inconspicuous they are all right so
and it was painful she said yeah you
know how long do i have left to live i
said
jail
i go gail that's that's an indiana jones
not here you're okay
okay scary you could have really messed
with her with that answer you know
thought about it don't don't prank her
in that situation well you got about
nine minutes
all right here have some toast yes is
that how you're gonna spend your last
nine
minutes look outside right now tower
camp you know it's you know it's that
time when we're
almost there for dinner right live look
outside great looking shot here from our
tower cam this is on top of black
mountain look at the las vegas strip
clear skies great sunset some flow facts
for you because we talked about 100
degrees yesterday for death valley
that's focused on us here our average
first 90 degree day is april 16th april
15th right where our first 90 degree 90
degree day this year could be this
friday on march 25th if we don't reach a
friday we for sure are going to reach it
on saturday 74 for centennials right now
72 for some of the new neighborhoods
here to show you 75 downtown we're near
80 for the east side for sunrise manor
78 for green valley rhodes ranch
mountains edge and spanish trails you
guys at 74 degrees southern highlands
got a lot of eight news now viewers down
there 75 for you and 74 for anthem that
includes also silverado ranch
90 degrees right now for death valley
and we'll come close to 100 degrees
there by tomorrow and definitely on
friday 68 searchlight 78 sandy valley
the reason for the rapid warm-up again
is this high pressure this is situated a
little to the south right now and we'll
see these
disturbances kind of come up and over it
for the for tomorrow but then this will
really anchor in for friday and saturday
and this is what's going to happen we're
talking record heat possible especially
friday and saturday where our record is
87 degrees here's the forecast for those
days that hasn't changed and then on
sunday too the record is 88 degrees we
could reach that come very close to that
on sunday but notice the cloud cover so
that could allow our temperatures again
not to reach those full highs so we'll
wait and see how it all turns out but
right now we're expecting above normal
temperatures as far as your wind speeds
go here your neighborhoods notice you
won't see any big colors on here because
those winds should stay fairly tame and
fairly light for thursday friday and
some of saturday except i think saturday
we'll see those winds pick up a little
bit more not morning but later on a day
as the day progresses so here's your
evening planner seven o'clock tonight 74
degrees very comfortable
at nine o'clock 67 still very nice
tonight no jacket needed clear skies
notice your wind staying light and for
eight news now at 11 don't forget to
join us clear skies 62 degrees winds
stay down about three miles per hour and
then at 8 a.m 58 degrees sunny skies on
tap for your thursday highs tomorrow in
the mid to high 80's so our first 80's
of the year on tap for all areas area
wide for tomorrow will be even hotter
look at this death valley almost 100
degrees tomorrow 98 for you 82 boulder
city 92 for loveland here's your eight
day forecast now like we said we'll warm
up to the 90s slight chances for showers
on monday and tuesday and much cooler
70s that is your most accurate forecast
denise